حاولت روسيا منذ الصيف التغلب على نكساتها
الثلاثه صار كيب في الشمال الشرقي لمن في
الشرق واخرسون في الجنوب بالتوجه نحو احدى
اقدم مدن اوكرانيا بخموت الواقعه في الشرق
القروصه بكل ثقلهم هناك جبهه المحصنه يبلغ
طولها نحو 15 كيلو مترا استعانوا بباكنر
وسحبوا وقوات من جبهه اخرى
نيهان الروسي لكن هل هو كذلك ام مغامره
غير محسوبه يبدو ان موسكو او قاعه نفسها
في الفخ التقدم بطيء الخسائر كبيره روسيا
تمضي رغم ذلك بينما الخسائر الاكبر تاتي
في جبهات اخرى وليست فقط عسكريه بل حتى
نفسيا الهجمات وصلت للعنق الروسيه
اوكرانيا استهدفت قاعدتين اجاويتين انجلش
التي تقع في منطقه سيرته في يجلب في منطقه
ريازان عند تحديدا لديها اهميه استراتيجيه
كبيره وهي واحده من قاعدتين استراتيجيتين
للقاذفات توجد فيهما القدرات النوويه
الروسيه المحموله جوا
برعت اوكرانيا التكتكيه كما وصفتها
الجارديان استمرت الي استهدفت لتستهدف
المطارات روسيه عبر المسيارات في مقاطع
الروسيه المحاديه لاوكرانيا لكن هناك ما
هو اخطر على روسيا قد يكون مدينه من
بيوتيفول او ما يعرفون بمفتاح الجنوب
اوكرانيا استغلت هاجس روسيا ببخوت وضربت
من اليوتيوب والمستعينه بدعم واشنطن الى
شنطته صواريخ الامر ذاته حصل في خرسون
التي استعادتها كيابه التهديد لموسكو
يتزايده القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل الان على
ضفه الشرقيه لنهر النيفر مقابل خرسون وما
قواتها الان على وضع انظمه صواريخ هان
وينكس على الضفه الغربيه يعني انها قادره
على اسقاط ميوتي بول وماذا يعني سقوط
المدينه انهيار خط الدفاع الروسي على طول
الطريق الى خرسون والكارثه على موسكو قد
تكون اكبر القوات الاوكرانيه قد تكتسب
طريقا مباشره الى شبه الجزيره
البعض والتي اصبحت ساحه لمعركه دميه بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه لكن خبراء
عسكريين تحدثوا عن عدم قدره القوات
الروسيه تحقيقا نجاحات هجوميه كبيره حتى
اذوبان الكامل للجليد بسبب صعوبه تقدمها
الان هذا القتال العنيف على هذه المنطقه
يعود لاسباب سياسيه ومعنويه بالنسبه
لروسيا وبالاخص بعد الانسحابات المتتاليه
للقوات الروسيه كان اخرها من خرسون
مؤسسه مجموعه العسكريه والتي تدعم القوات
الروسيه فيها معركه اكد على ان موعد
الاستلائي على هذه المنطقه ليس بالقريب
لان باخ موت هي منطقه كبيره محسنه يوجد
فيها ض هو حواجز مائيه ولان الجيش
الاوكراني على استعداد جيد ويقاوم بشده